will fans ever see the director's curse
of suicide squad while it's unclear if
david ayer's curt will ever be
officially released there's plenty of
information online about how the two
versions of the film differ here's what
the director's cut of suicide squad
would have looked like
the introductory comic con 2015 suicide
squad trailer
hinted at a hauntingly gritty movie set
to an eerie rendition of i started a
joke
it left the viewer taught with ominous
anticipation along with a sinking
feeling that survival rates would be low
successfully capturing the ethos of
suicide squad comic books
these aren't inspiring tales of
superheroes overcoming great odds
they're centered around repeated themes
of violence
incarceration torture and death hence
the name suicide squad
aya claims his film's midnight palette
was inspired by christopher nolan's dark
knight trilogy
and his version is more akin to todd
phillips joker by the time it hit
theaters however
audiences were left with a notably
lighter movie both literally and
figuratively
please don't touch me please don't touch
me according to ayer drastic changes
were made to his quote
soulful drama by quote shell-shocked
warner brothers executives
concerned about scathing reviews from
batman v superman dawn of justice
as well as the wild success of deadpool
in an effort to capture
some of that box office magic suicide
squad was transformed into a more
comedic film
according to lady falcon's interview
with richard cetrone ben affleck's stunt
double he shot a few additional action
scenes that never made it to theaters i
did a little more with the car like
trying to get into the car
trying to get through the roof so i did
a little more the car in question is a
lamborghini batman jumps on top of or
joker is driving it
cetrone describes the scene in which
batman can be seen attempting to cut
into the roof of the car
with something like an oxy fuel torch
apparently batman's role was always
intended to be limited
and the additional material feature in
the character doesn't have as large an
impact as other changes in a possible
director's cut
however even if it's not a large amount
more bats is always a good thing
though she's a key character in the
theatrical version the introduction of
june moon and her alter ego enchantress
feels rushed in suicide squad rather
than highlighting the importance of
enchantress's vast powers
or going into more detail about how
archaeologist june moon was possessed by
the ancient sorceress
this part of the story gets glossed over
like a side note aya has noted he wanted
suicide squad to open with june moon and
enchantress
rather than jumping right to meeting the
ill-fated crew he also went on to say
the two characters
have a more solid arc in his cut rumors
abound that these deleted scenes include
better insight into the nature of joon
moon
and rick flag's romantic relationship if
so this would add weight to the film's
climax
which pivots so heavily upon rick's
feelings for june
many of the final costuming choices in
suicide squad stirred controversy among
fans of being either too sexualized or
not true enough to their comic book
counterparts
like all other aspects of production the
last call and character looks was out of
air's hands
however enchantress's final look took
the most drastic term from his initial
vision
unlike the grungy temptress and chains
presented in the theatrical cut
concept art for aya's enchantress
mesmerizes with an ethereal beauty
encasing an airy confection of light and
colour
this would have been a far lovelier more
tasteful way to portray the potent magic
flowing through enchantress
there's a long-running trope in suicide
squad comic books that says on every
mission
one new recruit doesn't believe they
actually have a live bomb implant in
their neck
and has to learn the hard way as a
result since these characters never last
longer than a few minutes
they are usually low grade villains no
one in the audience will be sad to see
go
as a result readers of the comics
weren't that surprised at slipknot's
lack of screen time in theaters
however like other aspects of the film
reduced during the final editing process
his part in the story feels incomplete
according to adam beach the actor who
portrayed the rope obsessed villain he
filmed a flashback sequence
maybe one day we'll see how slipknot
actually got caught
the extended cut of suicide squad which
is not to be confused with the
hypothetical director's cut of the film
is 13 minutes longer than the theatrical
version most of that time comprises
additional footage from harley quinn's
flashbacks
throughout the film including an
extended view of joker's escape from
arkham while his cronies wreak havoc on
the medical center
joker can be seen killing someone with a
baseball bat or while dr quinzel is
being wrestled onto an examination table
then the two would be abusive lovers
have a discussion over the merits of
quinzel's therapy methods before cutting
back to the original version where joker
says
oh i'm not gonna kill you i'm just gonna
hurt you
really really bad
another extended cut details what
happened later that night leading up to
quinzel's transformation into harley
quinn
the extended cut still falls short of
filling all plot holes however
supposedly the air curt would make use
of these scenes to include additional
insight
into the harsh realities of their
relationship and more joker in general
one trait that makes joker so
terrifyingly dangerous is his chaotic
unpredictability this is something
monster t as played by common during
harley's club flashback scene had to
learn the hard way
when he offended joker drawing a
perceived inappropriate encounter
with harley regardless of motives
monster team meets an untimely end at
the hands of joker
in the theatrical version according to
ayer even more insight in the joker's
twisted minds can be found in his
version of this scene
instead of shooting him joker
intimidates monster t into taking his
own life
three official trailers were released
before suicide squad hit theaters
all containing scenes that never made it
to the final cut this has fueled the
feeling among fans that extensive
material
was lost in production and increased
demand for an air cut
according to ayer one deleted story arc
had to do with katana aya has said that
karen fukuhara's sword-wielding
character played a bigger role in his
cut
this makes sense considering how little
of katana made into the final film
according to ayer katana was originally
supposed to be taken over by enchantress
and turn on the squad we get glimpses of
this and not one but two different
trailers
as we see shots of katana's eyes going
black and more but the theatrical cut
never makes use of this sublot
for all its perceived shortcomings the
theatrical cut of suicide squad did get
one thing right
margot robbie as harley quinn for the
first time since the character was
created by paudini and bruce tim
more than 25 years ago harley was
finally seen on the big screen and fans
loved it unfortunately ayers said that
his original plans for harley which
would have included a more complex look
at her relationship with the joker
were eviscerated by the studio instead
of the tragic violent codependence the
two have shared since day one
their twisted relationship was reduced
to a classic love story which is
incredibly disturbing to those familiar
with their history aya has suggested his
version of the movie puts more emphasis
on harley quinn
and her journey towards independence
from the joker we certainly see some of
this in the sequel birds of prey
but perhaps the air cut would shed even
more light on it
part of harley's independent streak in
the air curt manifests itself in a fling
between harley and deadshot this is a
nod to source materials at the 2011 new
52 suicide squad comic books where floyd
and harley do indeed hook up
this may seem confusing for those who
have only seen harley with joker but
over the years harley has had flings
with various characters she's even
discovered that she's bisexual and
polyamorous
as seen in the harley quinn animated
series and more recent comic book
appearances a subplot romance between
harley and deadshot not only makes sense
but would also explain the chemistry the
two shared on screen
one of the more memorable suicide squad
scenes takes place when harley makes a
daring escape from a rooftop
onto joker's helicopter her moment of
glory is short-lived however because she
tumbles out onto the rooftop below
moments later
how she comes to fall however differs
between the theatrical version and aer's
cut
in theaters an airborne projectile
strikes the helicopter
violently knocking harley backwards it's
edited to further perpetuate the idea
that joker really loves harley as he's
shown yelling in despair when he tries
in vain to keep her from falling out
aya has said in his version joker pushed
her but not to kill her in a fit of
jealous rage
over her new friends this sounds more
like the joker fans are familiar with
considering his prior abuses include
throwing harley through a glass window
from several stories up
according to ayer his original plans for
joker included much more story
including a deal with enchantress that
would have seen the two basically team
up to the point that joker would be
around a lot more in the third act of
the film
joker's pitch would have allowed him to
set himself up as king of gotham
providing a deeper motivation for his
pursuit of the squad in the first place
it also helps explain another scene
first glimpse in trailers later cut from
the theatrical release
in one such scene joker's unnerving
laugh is heard echoing throughout the
chamber where the squad is fighting
enchantress and
incubus during the climax of the film
most of the information about ayu's
vision for suicide squad comes directly
from insights he shared in social media
posts
one exception to this concerns a deleted
juicy plot twist detailed on a leaked
script page
it contains a confrontation between the
squad and the temporary team-up between
enchantress and joker who have taken
amanda waller hostage
the leaked script page provides
noteworthy insight into joker's
disregard for other living beings and
harley's conflicted loyalties when asked
on twitter if the scene was ever shot
aya replied
shots and edited of course you are not
permitted to see it my friend
if the footage exists maybe it could be
restored in an aircraft release
another notable difference between the
ayer and theatrical kurds concerned the
fate of el diablo his haunting backstory
was almost axed along with other scenes
considered too dark for a pg-13 film
but the director managed to convince
executives of its importance to the
overall story
aya later called the fight to keep
diablo's backstory the only battle he
won with executives
one change that aircut would make to
diablo story though is his final fate
in the director's version diablo doesn't
die while fighting for the common good
instead he survives the entire length of
the film
as it turns out aya never intended for
the squad to battle incubus during the
grand finale the director said on
twitter that his original plans included
a battle with a parademon boss that was
cut while prepping the movie
paving the way for incubus instead
parademons are ruthless monsters serving
in the army of legendary dc comics
villain darkseid and we've already seen
them pop up in the dc eu
thanks to justice league since darkseid
and his minions already loom over the
whole dc eu
ayur's parademon plan would have tied
things together even more
unfortunately continuity is something
warner brothers struggles with
especially when compared to the
comprehensive multi-year plan executed
by marvel studios
for dc fans it's difficult not to be
envious of their success
until more is unveiled concerning a
possible release date for the
hypothetical a occurred
fans will have to wait for this possible
redemption with baited breath
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you